Dave it's a contest aroni lipstick says
the beats ax is SIA its most successful
compact seeit has sold 5.4 million in
the last 33 years now the fifth
generation is being released as an
all-new ax beats ax say it looks back
proudly on a record year 2016 was the
company's best year ever and it's still
on a roll with the fifth generation of
the best-selling Ibiza
unlike many competitors say 'it hasn't
made the car longer but wider nine
centimetres wider now it's based on
Volkswagens MQB a zero platforms
[Music]
Ronnie says the widening the car made it
possible to use wider wheels and that
greatly increases driving stability say
it offers three three cylinder gasoline
engines we're testing the most powerful
one the one litre 85 kilowatt TSI at the
end of the year a new 1.5 litre 110
kilowatt TSI will roll off the assembly
lines the starting price for the new
Ibiza is just under 13,000 euros in
Germany technologically the Ibiza has
been completely redesigned the
developers goal was to take a giant step
forward and safety appearance power and
comfort
the noisette Medusa at Ibiza is
chock-full of technologies as Ronnie for
example a choice of four driving modes
three are predetermined eco sport and
normal the fourth is for the owner to
set as he desires you can set the
suspension and the steering how you like
it which is very unusual in a compact
Ronnie says the New Salem Itza is
fabulous big 18-inch wheel rims and LED
headlights give the Ibiza an elegant
appearance the Leon clearly sets the
tone for the e beaches design clear
sharp contours the front and back
overhangs are short which increases
stability and gives the Ibiza a dynamic
sporty look the extended wheelbase and
the shape of the windows underscore the
cars size
[Music]
in the cockpit the central eight-inch
touchscreen is conspicuous all the
buttons that used to flank it are now
integrated in the glass surface of
course the interior is the biggest
beneficiary of the newly Beach's broader
shape this was Allison Ronny is
enthusiastic about how well the new
generation Ibiza has turned out
thanks to the new MQB a zero platform
the car not only seems bigger it is
bigger and you notice it in the interior
and in the trunk volume in the future
the Ibiza will be available only as a
five-door many aspects of the new
compact are as good or even better than
in the larger Leone the Ibiza doesn't
seem to have any weaknesses and yet it's
hardly more expensive than its
predecessor but that could end up
meaning that sayit will sell fewer
Leone's
you